what's up everyone this is Anthony
papiano
most of you know me as pump you're
listening to off the chain
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off
Brad kam is a co-founder of unstoppable
domains in this conversation we
discussed free speech censorship China
the societal impact of unstoppable
domains how exactly it works what the
technical challenges they overcame were
and they also announced a new domain
extension dot crypto I'm really excited
about what they're building they're
replacing crypto addresses with an easy
to remember domain name and right now
they're running a buy one get one free
domain offer starting with the launch of
this episode you can check it out at
unstoppable domains com
I'm gonna grab pomp crypto and I hope
you grab one as well enjoy the episode
skrt skrt want to know who has the best
URL crypto com
that's right crypto calm there crypto
platform with one goal mother and mass
adoption that's why we're all here we're
trying to get crypto in every wallet
crypto calm is helping people do that
through buying earning lending and card
payment everything you could want and
crypto calm go help your boy out tell
them pump sent you download the app or
visit crypto calm palms got you always
everyone to get into mining and didn't
know how don't worry your boy pops
gotcha everybody got some electricity
and Wi-Fi all you got to do is go to
coin mine comm you buy a coin mine it's
like an Xbox or a Playstation that helps
you turn your electricity into Bitcoin
that's right you purchase it it shows up
at your doorstep you pull it out of the
box you plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi
five minutes or less you're mining
Bitcoin all you have to do is control it
from the mobile app they provide and
then you receive over-the-air updates
that add new coins and new features on a
consistent basis kind of like how Tesla
does over-the-air updates and updates
the car software just you're updating
your coin mind consumer mining made easy
that's right go to coin mine calm
pomp setya and thank me later as many of
you know crypto investors store their
digital assets on exchanges or in cold
storage for long-term safekeeping
however this strategy doesn't help them
grow their investment holdings or build
overall wealth with the new block by
interest account users can now securely
store their Bitcoin or Ethernet block by
and receive 6% annual interest paid
monthly and cryptocurrency 6% is an
absurdly high rate it's the best rate in
the industry I highly suggest you go
check out block Viacom / pump again
that's block 5 com / pop to sign up and
start earning crypto today if you follow
Bitcoin and crypto you've probably heard
of eToro they're the world's number one
social trading platform and I love it
they've got more than 10 million other
traders that love it - and guess what
they just launched in the United States
eToro offers access to the world's most
popular crypto currencies including
Bitcoin aetherium and others with the
smartest trading tools and the ability
to connect with the best traders around
the world there's no better place to
build your perfect portfolio if you're
new to Bitcoin and crypto you can test
the waters with a 100 thousand dollar
virtual trading feature but if you're
more experienced you can create custom
technical charts and use eToro social
fees to inform your trading decisions
they've got transparent fees and so you
never miss out they also have an
easy-to-use application available an
iPhone Android or any web browser you
can get started today in just a few
clicks at eternal calm again that's
eToro comm get VIP access to Bitcoin and
crypto markets today Anthony pomp lion-o
is a partner at Morgan Creek Digital all
opinions expressed by pump or his guests
on this podcast are solely their
opinions and do not reflect the opinions
of Morgan Creek digital or Morgan Creek
Capital Management you should not treat
any opinion expressed by pomp as a
specific inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only
alright guys bang bang I'm super excited
I've got Brad here with me he's working
on probably one of the more powerful
ideas that I've seen in the in the
crypto and blockchain space so I'm
excited to kind of go over what an
unstoppable domain
is and kind of what they're up to so
thanks so much for taking the time and
come in and do this bride thanks so much
for having me excited for sure let's
start with your background and kind of
what you did pre blockchain
cryptocurrency and Bitcoin yes so I've
been an entrepreneur since I was in
college started in the real estate world
bought up some some houses during the
last economic crash 2009-2010 era 2012
moved to San Francisco to get into the
startup game worked on a startup called
talkable which is a referral marketing
software company so spent six years
working on that but was spending a lot
of nights thinking about crypto so it's
time to get in the game for sure and do
you remember the first time that you
ever you know saw Bitcoin or a
blockchain and kind of what your thought
was I read a wired article in like 2011
the rise and fall of Bitcoin and it
didn't think much of it but when I moved
to San Francisco in December of 2012 I
moved in to this place called xx mission
which is like a Bitcoin hacker house I
think the second crypto Exchange in the
US was launched out of the basement some
of the earliest crypto meetups were
there so I when I moved to San Francisco
just basically everybody I I met was a
was a Bitcoin fanatic and I bit the bug
pretty soon after and have been able to
stop thinking about it that was almost 7
years ago it's awesome all right so
would you would you do first in the
crypto space and then how did you
eventually call the idea front stoppable
domains yeah so at first I was really
just an investor advised a couple of
companies kind of tinkered around and
then in 2017 my co-founder Matt came up
with this this idea to build to build
domain names on block chains and to kind
of turn it into this into this into this
sort of you know consumer consumer
friendly product and III got roped in
somewhere a few months after got it and
I think a lot of people probably heard
of unstoppable domains they've seen the
press coverage etc let's start from the
very beginning like just what exactly is
it and how does it work yeah so when
stopple domains is a registry business
so it's very similar to like a Verisign
which owns comm except for our domain
name systems our own box chains and the
idea is that blockchain domains do two
things that regular domains can't do the
first is to simplify your crypto
payments to replace all of your crypto
addresses
with this single human-readable name so
you could have like pumped out whatever
you can attach your Bitcoin aetherium
litecoin all of your crypto addresses to
this one domain you tell it to me I type
it into a wallet and pay you I don't
need to know your addresses I don't need
to see your dresses I don't even need to
know which crypto you want to receive
because you've already attached the the
currencies that you accept to your
domain that's payments you can also use
them to build on sensible websites and
the way this works is you can point your
domain to content on like a
decentralized storage network like IP FS
and then the domain is essentially an
asset on a blockchain it sits inside of
your wallet just like a cryptocurrency
so the combination of having a domain
that you control that's self custody by
you and content that's on a
decentralized storage network means you
can build a website that only you can
put up and only you can take down and
this is really different from the way
that traditional domains work where if
you have like a dot-com you have a
registrar like GoDaddy or something like
that
they're your custodian they can move the
domain around for you if they get a
court order they're gonna take it same
is true for your content your content is
probably sitting on like Amazon Web
Services or something like that same
thing if they don't like what you're
doing they can flip off your website it
takes only a few minutes or also if they
get a court order that websites coming
down not a huge deal in the United
States but around the world there's a
lot of places and a lot of people that
are putting up things that you and I
wouldn't think are wrong that are
getting censored and taken down and the
user the user tools are the tools
themselves are built in such a way that
companies and governments have complete
control over yeah so we'll get to some
of the censors censorship stuff in a
second let's dig a little deeper in the
technical components of this right
because I think the idea is pretty easy
to understand of just hey there's going
to be unstoppable domains you know great
naming on your guy's part but how does
this work from a technical standpoint
and how do you actually prevent there
being somebody who has the control to
take down the domains yes so what
happens is is we launch our registry on
a public blockchain so it's a smart
contract on a public blockchain each
domain is essentially like it's
essentially like an NFT it is like a non
fungible tokens or each domain is unique
each domain is an
set that sits inside of your wallet just
like a cryptocurrency so it has the same
security model as you storing your own
Bitcoin or used to write your own
etherium so you need the private key in
order to move it around and the same is
true for when you add information to it
so what you're really doing is you're
pointing your domain to your content and
your content is sitting on a
decentralized storage network or
something like that and the way the way
it works is is you sign a message with
that private key the same private key
that controls the domain and you say my
IP FS hash equals this and so because
you're the only one that can write that
ipfs hash to your domain you're the only
one that can update the content and so
the domain is just like a cryptocurrency
someone needs to get your private key in
order to move it and then your web
content same thing someone needs to get
your private key in order to update it
got it and so as you're doing this can
you do it on Bitcoin a theory I'm kind
of any public blockchain or is this
specific to just a certain few of them
so in order to make this really robust
you need to launch the smart contract on
a public blockchain like an aetherium or
something like that but it doesn't
really from the end-user perspective
what winds up happening is you can
attach any cryptocurrency address to a
domain that's sitting on say the
etherion blockchain so if bitcoin is
your client is the primary way that you
receive money fine attach your Bitcoin
address aetherium address litecoin
address it doesn't really matter so
basically any single domain any single
domain name that we create has the
ability to receive any cryptocurrency
got it and but it's all built on top of
the etherium blockchain where this this
exists and works best right now so we
build on multiple block chains we built
we built our first system on silica
blockchain which is another smart
contract platform that does sharding
we're building our second one on
aetherium got it and as you're building
this what were some of the technical
challenges that you guys had to figure
out or kind of get around that maybe
other people either hadn't figured out
yet or you guys had unique solutions too
yeah I think it's sort of like the
biggest problem as we see this is it's
really more around there's two things
there's the the kind of the ecosystem
problem meaning that you need to get
lots and lots of applications inside the
ecosystem to support it and then there's
the user tools problem so this idea of
a decentralized domain names I think
it's been floating around in the crypto
world for a long time there was named
coin very early on there were some other
attempts on smart contract block chains
as well but the problem has been how do
you get all the applications to connect
together and how do you make it super
easy for users so a lot of the things
that have been difficult that we've been
solving for are how do we make it super
simple for users to be able to do things
like sign messages with their private
key store domains easily easily in a
self custody way all of these things
it's really about making what are
otherwise difficult things easy in the
UI and so if you were to go for example
to unstoppable domains calm and and
manage your domain we have a little
management section you buy a domain you
can check out very easily with crypto or
credit card the domain gets transferred
to a wallet that is rolled into our
application it's a self custody wallet
and then with a couple of clicks you can
copy and paste like a Bitcoin address
and click Save and then it writes them
it signs a message and writes a message
to the blockchain so you as the user
don't even realize necessarily that
that's what's happening all you see is I
saved an address to my domain what's
really happening is if there's a
transaction on the blockchain underneath
one of the things that we did is we
cover the fees which helps to make this
a little bit easier but getting it all
the way down to this really simple user
experience has been probably the the
most the most challenging thing got it
and so how is it going so far in terms
of you guys obviously built this that
works that the technology is there
you've got a great name you've raised
some capital what are you seeing from a
user adoption standpoint yeah so I think
things of things have been rolling
pretty fast so we we started selling our
first domain name system in March as of
today we've registered more than a
hundred thousand donated system here to
date and also pretty big for any
registry business even for the
traditional domain name world so people
are buying domains claiming domains
adding addresses and starting to use
them for payments very cool and so walk
us through how you guys actually make
money in this system right you go from
zero to a hundred thousand domains
what's kind of the business model and
how do you see that evolving
so we sell domains it's quite simple the
domains are priced between $20 and up to
$10,000 for the most premium domains
it's a one-time fee though so over time
we'll be launching some subscription
services for advanced features they'll
be optional you'll always be able to
just buy a domain interact with it
control it forever yourself got it I'll
start doing some math in my head a
hundred thousand times 220 is a big
number um so I think that you know where
you guys can go with this there's kind
of look at it like you guys are coming
up on a fork in the road right and you
can take this a whole bunch of different
ways right there's the payment angle
there's the domain angle there's a whole
bunch of things around societal impact
that we'll get into in a minute what's
kind of next for you guys yeah so I
think that the the really the really
powerful thing about this is that so in
the traditional world you've got
payments and payments is this very
separate concept you have to integrate
stripe you have to do all this kind of
crazy crazy stuff in order to get
payments into your website in the
blockchain world payments and websites
are essentially the same concept so
you're gonna have your domain you're
gonna have popped out whatever I'll be
able to send money to it you'll also be
able to host a website there and when I
send money to it I know that the web
content that is called that where your
advertising let's say you're advertising
a product or a service or whatever I
know that when I pay you I'm paying the
same person that put up this website so
it's basically like this concept of
payments and websites become one and if
you actually need both so if you want to
have if you want to have a truly
uncensored business you need to be able
to receive money and you need to be able
to host content so and I know there was
another question there in terms of
what's next
so one one thing that I'd love to share
with your with your communities I think
they'll be they'll be excited about is
that we're getting ready to launch our
second domain extension it's going to be
on the etherion blockchain it's called
crypto and the idea is that it is going
to be the blockchain domain system for
the entire crypto community so you could
have like Pumped crypto and for example
will make sure that we'll make sure that
you get it you get pumped crypto and and
the other thing is is that so as when as
soon as this show goes live we're going
to be doing a 1/4
where you'll be able to buy our first
dimension is called dill so you'll be
able to buy a dildo mane and you'll
automatically get the same crypto domain
for any any domain that's larger than
seven characters so something that I
think I think as soon as this as soon as
the show goes live that'll be that'll be
something that the community will be
excited about for sure so help me
understand how hard is it for you to add
new kind of domain names right so the
dill crypto etc is this something where
you can add hundreds or thousands of
them in the future is it something where
you'll kind of stay concentrated around
four or five like what's the plan and
how difficult it is dad more it's
difficult from an ecosystem perspective
our goal is not to create a lot of
systems I think that too is probably is
probably plenty for a while there may be
some reason or some new features the
biggest reason might be to go and launch
on a new blockchain if there's a new
blockchain that winds up being more
efficient than aetherium but for now the
plan is to stick with these two zealand
crypto and you know we think you know
crypto is essentially the you know the
premium the premium domain name system
and so will be heavily focused on that
I'm holding out for pomp Bitcoin I like
it though
all right I want to get into some of the
meat of this which is the societal
impact right obviously like I said in
the beginning is a really powerful idea
around unstoppable domains let's start
with the the positive side and the part
that I think is non-controversial
especially in the developed world
Western world which is you guys are
going to take a big swipe at the ability
for people to censor content prevent
access to information to prevent freedom
of speech etc maybe just talk a little
bit about how you guys philosophically
think about this impact and in kind of
how you think it actually will play out
in reality yeah so this is this is the
reason why we why we started this
business this is the reason why I'm
motivated to wake up to wake up in the
morning and do this is because we
believe that anyone in the world should
be able to publish and transact without
fear of censorship companies governments
there's no one group or one person that
I trust to decide what is okay on the
inner
and this idea of allowing companies and
governments to be our gatekeepers has
continued to escalate you know the
internet I think started you know in the
90s and 2000's with this very anarchic
ethos and over time has become extremely
centralized to the point where it's
becoming kind of dangerous it's becoming
dangerous
to people around the world but I think
it's also becoming dangerous to people
in the US as well and it's getting worse
and as we see sort of a rise of
authoritarianism around the world
I think it's connected I think it's
connected to the centralization of data
and that this is this might be one of
the biggest risks we face and our only
hope is to decentralize it we need to
take the power out of these groups yeah
and so it's a really interesting way of
looking at I think a lot of folks are
saying hey the fact that we've given up
so much data the fact that we don't have
access to this data is a huge problem I
think what you're saying is it's not so
much that we've given up the data or
given access to the data it's actually
that it's we've given it to a
centralized authority that centralized
authority we have won no recourse
against into they're able to do a lot of
maybe not nefarious things as much as
just things that you or I wouldn't agree
with yeah and I think that you know I
think the context again in the u.s. is
quite different you know in the u.s.
it's you know there aren't that many
groups of people that are being censored
at least not for legal activity but if
you look at it around the world it's
very different you know there yeah I
would say more than half of the world
does not live does not live in a free
society and so legal speech or what we
would consider to be legal or okay
speech you know political opposition
other unpopular ideas these types of
things or even unpopular businesses that
are considered legal or getting censored
all over the place they get censored at
the domain level they get censored at
the website content level and they get
centered censored at the payment
processing level and a blockchain domain
name system solves all those problems
for sure and so is the idea here that
not only one you can kind of give people
a peaceful way to fight back right
against a lot of that authority nary ISM
I said that word wrong that's fine ever
gonna laugh and then also the censorship
or is it a thing where or kind of
additionally there will also be this
whole ecosystem built on top of
unstoppable domains and you'll kind of
get some of the old existing world
to be able to fight back but also
there's a whole new world of content and
you know folks who will use the
unstoppable domains to build new things
as well yes I think it's actually really
similar to Bitcoin and cryptocurrency in
general where if you look at the history
of Bitcoin and cryptocurrency you know
it started out with use cases around you
know heavily censored activities people
doing things that they just couldn't do
in the other world but over time we're
starting to see you know more
traditional businesses move into it
because the technology actually works
better it's cheaper to send a
transaction it's faster to tense in to
transaction the technology is more
robust than what we've currently been
using and the same is true here for
blockchain domain name systems where you
know it may be that early on it's going
to start with you know Chinese political
dissidents that are not able that are
not able to publish in any other
platform without it getting taken down
but over time we'll find that you know
this is just better like you can you can
sell a domain name you don't need an
escrow agent you can transfer a domain
name in 30 seconds without without
without those types of rules that exist
in the current world you'll be able to
ultimately you'll be able to store
content in a cheaper way because you're
not only having to go to Amazon Web
Services you'll be able to access
anybody in the world's computer who
wants to put up who wants to offer their
servers for storage space so ultimately
this technology is more robust and we
definitely see a future where
traditional businesses move over to this
because it works better skirt school
want to know who has the best URL crypto
com that's right
crypto comm their crypto platform with
one goal mother mass adoption that's why
we're all here we're trying to get
crypto in every wallet crypto comm is
helping people do that through buying
earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto comm
go help your boy out
tell them pump sends you download the
app or visit crypto comm pumps got you
always everyone to get into mining and
didn't know how don't worry your boy
pops gotcha everybody got some
electricity and Wi-Fi all you got to do
is go to coin mine comm you buy a coin
mine it's like an Xbox or a PlayStation
that helps you
turn your electricity into Bitcoin
that's right you purchase it it shows up
at your doorstep you pull it out of the
box you plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi
five minutes or less you're mining
Bitcoin all you have to do is control it
from the mobile app they provide and
then you receive over-the-air updates
that add new coins and new features on a
consistent basis kind of like how Tesla
does over-the-air updates and updates
the car software just you're updating
your coin mind consumer mining made easy
that's right go to coin mine com tell
them pump Sencha and thank me later
one more word from our sponsor blocked
by their new interest account allows you
to securely deposit your Bitcoin or
ether at block five and receive 6%
annual interest paid monthly and
cryptocurrency
this rate actually compounds so you
receive a 6.2 percent APY which is very
attractive given the alternatives so you
can actually take your Bitcoin you can
deposit it with block Phi and get paid
an interest rate of 6% in return go
check out block 5 comm slash pump again
block 5 comm slash pump to sign up and
start earning interest on your crypto
today so that's a lot of the kind of
positive societal impact I think that
there's a lot of nuance in there each
situation is different and the devil is
kind of in the details I would be remiss
if I didn't ask about comes and
attraction to a lot of this right I
think the people who see Oh an
unstoppable domain yes there's probably
a positive impact but also there could
be negative sides right what if the kind
of this technology or this product falls
into the bad actors hands right so
whether it is somebody who's posting
child pornography or human trafficking
right all this kind of stuff that today
it gets censored by being taken down or
prevented access to for people
if the domains are unstoppable one can
that content persist and how do you guys
think about that as you know product
creators and then kind of the impact
that could be used by these bad people
yeah and I think the same you know this
were the same arguments were thrown out
about Bitcoin itself and I own
cryptocurrencies early on and I think
that there's no there's a few things I
think the first thing to keep in mind is
that the majority of people around the
world are using these tools and want to
use these tools because the current
tools are not able to serve them
the majority of us and the majority of
uses are not for these bad actors so I
think that's a that's you know that's an
important thing to keep in mind for
crypto and I think the same is that same
will be true for blockchain domains but
the other part of it is that these
things these bad things they happen on
the regular Internet - they already
exist and persist in the world so I
think it's challenging to get it to zero
no matter how hard we try but we will
try because we don't want those things
to happen the reason we're doing this is
because we want to promote global free
speech we don't want to help bad people
do bad things and there's a lot of ways
that this will work that I think will
ultimately be better than the way that
the current that the current internet
functions and the way it works is is
that at the protocol level you can do
anything anybody can interact with the
public blockchain and your buddy can
sign a message and write information to
the public blockchain theoretically
anybody could read that information but
in reality with the commercial Internet
with the commercial decentralized
Internet what's going to happen is
applications aren't going to serve up
stuff that they object to or stuff that
is illegal so what's gonna wind up
happening is your browser will choose
you know will essentially choose okay
this is content that we don't want to
serve you and that'll be way better
because you don't get one view on what's
okay you know this browser over here
might say you know it might take a
specific moral moral moral opinion on
this or that content and show it to you
or not show it to you this other browser
might take a different view and what's
gonna wind up happening is you'll choose
your browser you'll choose your
application your application will choose
your internet but we're gonna get dozens
of different versions hundreds of
different versions and through that
we'll wind up getting protected from
cases where things that we really should
see or things that we really want to see
we're not going to be stopped from
seeing them and - is this almost like
when you're describing this the first
minute jumps to mind is like it's like a
product stack or technology stack for a
certain ethics morals and perspectives
right where you'll say hey this protocol
with this web browser with this
application in the web browser etc gives
me access to a certain view of the world
whereas somebody else may not do that is
that a fair way to kind of look at like
a technology or product stack
on a specific perspective ethics or
moral kind of spectrum or do you look at
it a little bit differently yeah I think
maybe we look at it slightly differently
so the way the way that we look at it is
that technology tools themselves should
not take an opinion technology tools the
only way to get a 100% safe and secure
system is to have a system where the
user controls their own activities
completely if any company in the
individual any group even unstoppable
domains if anybody gets to decide or get
then then that's going to be that's
going to break down the safety and
security of the system so the system
needs to be agnostic now we also live in
the real world as do as does everybody
and what's going to wind up happening is
you and I are not going to want to have
a completely anarchic internet where all
of this terrible stuff is served even if
we want and promote global free speech
we personally I mean I don't want to see
that stuff you don't want to see that
stuff so what's going to wind up
happening is we're gonna want our
applications to do this for us and so
that's how it's gonna that's how it's
gonna work
we'll be you know facilitating that and
enabling that but at its core what we're
really focused on is tools that take no
opinion about about about what you do
and this is exactly how Bitcoin and
aetherium work miners don't evaluate
whether or not they think you're a good
person before they process your
transaction and that's the reason why we
have a safe and secure system yeah it's
a really interesting way to look at it
and you know one that I think has a lot
of validity what do you think is kind of
the first pressure test right in terms
of as as this happens if there is some
nefarious actor who comes into the
system like where do you guys anticipate
some of those issues popping up is it
more kind of in the conversation so I
can in the press or you know general
population or is it something from more
technical standpoint where there's
actual security threats or something
like that I think it will probably I
mean this is just speculation but I
think it'll probably be more like a
public opinion type thing but I think
that the the the first lightning rods
we're gonna see are gonna be lightning
rods around free speech where there's
gonna be some people that want this
thing to be said there's gonna be other
people that don't want this thing to be
said and there's gonna be a fight about
it and I would broadly say I
say that's a that's a good thing that's
that's a good conversation to have and
it's okay for me to say this content is
good and you say this content is bad you
can choose your own Internet we don't
all have to agree and I think that's
going to make a more diverse world
that's gonna make a more robust
technology stack this is gonna be a
better version of the future yeah I
think that's a very fair position to
take what what do you think is the big
inflection point here for for the
existing internet right so existing
corporation successor to say look you
know I need an unstoppable domain I want
one of these on the blockchain is there
something that you're looking at at that
inflection point I think that what
you're gonna see most likely first is
you're gonna see traditional businesses
playing around with this sort of
technology for payments because they
don't have good payment solutions right
now especially not international payment
solutions so cryptocurrencies and
blockchain domains paired with crypto
currencies for payments are something
that's going to be relevant I think to
the traditional Internet world
relatively soon the point in time at
which they want to abandon their Amazon
Web Services and all these other tools
are going to be when this stack is more
robust and I think you know ultimately
if you look at it on a long enough time
line open-source wins open-source will
be better more robust stronger cheaper
all of these things but that's gonna
take time and initially I think these
tools will not be those things and
therefore the people that will be
focused on using them will be the people
that have this hair on fire problem
there'll be the people that are getting
censored right now W the people whose
domains are getting seized from them
there'll be the people whose content is
being switched off by various cloud
service providers so those are going to
be the places where you'll see it first
I think and then over time it's going to
be once the tech once the tech is better
and there will be that that inflection
point in the future that's when the
traditional world is gonna is gonna
start switching over for sure let's give
you the benefit the doubt and say you
build everything that your heart can
desire you and the team are wildly
successful what does this look like in
you know 10 15 20 years from today what
is that kind of ultimate ambition for
unstoppable domains the ultimate
ambition is to have
domains and websites on technology that
cannot be censored meaning that you can
build your website you can put it up you
can take it down no one can stop you
anyone around the world can view that
website if they want to that basically
the entire internet switches over to
this the current internet I you know if
you look at it from the sort of nuts and
bolts perspective is not a is not a safe
and secure place I mean if you just read
the news you will see like these systems
are not secure centralized systems have
this huge problem they are not secure
and ultimately this is the only way for
us to get complete security so the
entire Internet's gonna switch over to
this I love it
III think that if you can do half of
that you'll spot before I finish up I
always do rapid-fire questions what do
you think is the most important company
in crypto other than your own ooh good
question I would say probably I would
say probably one of the one of the big
exchanges so you know I'm a huge fan of
coinbase
they've been a great company and I think
they've you know they've they've they've
done it the right way in order to in
order to help spread crypto around the
world what's the one regulation you
would change or improve if you could ooh
that's a good question I would say
probably just more clarity there's just
it's not even I don't even I can't even
point to a regulation what I really can
point to is fear you know you talk to a
lawyer a lawyer says you should be
afraid of doing this or that with crypto
it's not illegal it doesn't violate any
specific rule but you should be afraid
because of lack of clarity so I would
say clarity that there is a category and
it's called securities and most of the
stuff in crypto is not that and and that
that we're you know that there's that
there's just clarity to operate for all
of these different all these different
parties what's your most controversial
thought in in crypto if you say it
everyone will go I completely disagree
I am cryptocurrency and blockchain
agnostic I don't care ultimately which
tools people use I want the technology
and the community to rise
across the board and you'll see this
playing out inside of the way that we
talk about our business and the way that
we build we don't actually care if you
want to use Bitcoin great if you want to
use Bitcoin cash great if you want to
use aetherium that's great too
we don't care in the tribalistic world
of cryptids a very controversial thought
but but one that is appreciated for sure
what's the most important book you've
ever read ooh that's a good question I
have you listen to the podcasts all I do
is good questions I'm gonna say I'm
gonna say one that sticks out to me and
that I read recently maybe not of all
time but radical markets radical markets
really impacted the way that I the way
that I think about you know what is an
ideal economic system and I also think
that it's just this like amazing Third
Way you know it's like it's not
socialist it's not libertarian
free-market it's this it's this other
thing that kind of can unite all the
different views around a pragmatic
version of how to build an accountant
economy that works yeah I haven't read
that I'll have to check it out for sure
I end each podcast letting the guest ask
me one question but first we talk a
Lian's
believer non-believer I mean there's
gotta be some aliens
the universe is just too big the the
thing now that I'm very interested in is
if we came in contact would we end up
being the superior species or do you
think that we would be submissive and
therefore maybe it's actually good that
we've never come in contact with them
reportedly I have to believe that
there's you know again just because of
the vastness of the universe that
there's probably both you know like I
think we've been you know whatever we've
been rolling as a species for maybe like
three hundred thousand years something
like that two or three hundred thousand
years maybe you go back to hominids we
got a couple million years there's got
to be somebody that's been evolving or
some group that's been evolving for like
I don't know a few hundred million or a
billion years so there's got to be some
that are ahead of us and some that are
behind us so I I guess I hope we bump
into the ones that are behind us it's
pretty scary to think about the idea
that there could it be some sort of
sentient beings that have been evolving
for
hundreds of millions of years definitely
all right one question do you have for
me to wrap it up I mean what's your
what's your favorite crypto company my
favorite company I was cheat and it's my
podcast so I can do whatever I want I
say Bitcoin just because I think from a
market standpoint you know the market is
determined that's the most valuable one
by market cap today but I do think that
you know if you take what you guys are
doing or there's some other people in
the market that are taking a lot of the
ethos of Bitcoin aetherium kind of you
know these ones that the market is
determined are super valuable so it's
not the actual technology alone it's the
ethos of what they're trying to do and
you're applying it to frankly kind of
what I think previously was perceived as
like nascent areas of crypto right so
blockchain domains etc but they're very
large markets in traditional world and
you take the ethos of these public block
chains and you start to apply it to
these areas one I think that you know
just like you guys have seen you see
very fast growth because there there are
a lot of people who want to eat those of
the crypto world combined with the same
services and products from the
traditional world but also I think what
you find is you're essentially building
a product for a global audience rather
than a developed world audience and you
know we're sitting here in New York City
in Manhattan like as far away from
understanding the the developing world
as possible for most people but but I do
find that a lot of people in crypto have
actually done a lot of travel they've
spent a lot of time they have friends
all over the world and so they're a
little bit more globalist in mindset and
so it's pretty interesting to to see you
know companies like yours and others
build along those ethos for for large
markers in the traditional world yeah
that's really cool and one of the things
that I find the most fascinating about
talking about this company is oftentimes
you know we're talking about censorship
on the Internet and we're talking about
these problems we talked we talked about
it to folks in America and they're a
little bit puzzled we talked about it to
folks that live almost anywhere else in
the world
and they get it immediately they're like
oh yeah I've had a domain seized oh yeah
you know you're not allowed to say what
you want to say in my country so it's
basically only in the United States
where where some of these concepts are
not completely clear
yeah it's you know oh yeah I had that
blog where I wrote one time about the
president I didn't say anything bad but
they just took it down because they had
the president's name in it right exactly
awesome and listen where can people find
out more about unstoppable domains and
find you on the Internet
yeah go to unstoppable domains calm and
as I mentioned before there's
essentially a buy one get one free for
the doc crypto as soon as this show
comes out so check out the website and
and yeah reach out to us we're on
telegram we're on Twitter we're we're
all over the place awesome well thanks
so much again for coming to do this want
to do it again in the future
hey everyone pop here if you like this
episode of off the chain and want to
help us take crypto to the top of the
Apple Spotify and other podcast charts
please do us a favor and rate review and
subscribe to review simply go to the
off-the-chain homepage scroll down until
you see the five blank stars taking 15
seconds to fill those stars in and leave
a quick review goes a long way and help
being us take the entire crypto
ecosystem to the top of the charts I
appreciate you listening and see you
next time on off the chain